people always say don't assume the worst
you excited yeah is it a boy or girl we
don't know
sometimes the worst is exactly what you
should assume
so my wife is in hospitals she's about
to give birth drive this is a family
emergency I'm your family emergency now
whatever it is that you want it's yours
this is the wife David where are you
you and your wife have a happy marriage
take away from my family
that's rude you interrupting me don't
you know what I don't need tonight
stress
let's just make wise decisions watch the
speed limits
you're not listening to me I will shoot
you
and this cop
I told you not to speed
we should play a little game I want you
to tell me the truth if you don't I am
going to kill Mr Happy trucker and this
waitress ready
you got me confused with someone else
really I'm not who you think I am told
you who I think you are so how did you
know you're not who I think you are
back down
getting good
not gonna die tonight
I dressed up for this I wanted to be a
hundred percent sex tonight and you cut
that in half I'm now 50 sex
people tend to think the more violent
the death the higher the heaven you go
it's better to rain in hell wouldn't you
agree
pick up the phone James what would you
go to me
what are you Dr Ross my psychiatrist